the program here was approved in
order to be a temporary solution for the
group of young immigrants known
as dreamers but after nine
years these young people continue to live with
uncertainty one of those young people is
manuel bernal mejía who came to the
united states when he was two  years ago on
Tuesday morning he testified in front of
congress approved to pick up it looks better
that more are fragments of pintame bernal
I have explained to myself that as an
emergency doctor he works day after day to
save the lives of others while his
own life is uncertain this because sometimes
Despite the fact that
President Bailen's administration is accepting new
daca applications, a lawsuit in the
state of Texas could end the
program, Democratic congressmen and
some Republicans say they
support the idea of ​​providing
permanent protections for these young people known
as dreamers, but  For the
past 20 years Congress has tried
unsuccessfully to ap  steal the
dream act bill
to see those permanent protections
including a path to citizenship
and this year the
promise regime may not succeed either as
Republicans say it
provides too many protections
for different types of immigrants in its current form  and
not only for dreamers reporting in
washington
alexandra limón